All right. Let's continue with a couple of other
stories that I want to mention to you. The George
Soros anti-Semitic media control conspiracy
theory is now coming out forcefully from the
mouth of the failed former President Donald Trump.
Trump's campaign in an email fundraising email now
suggests that George Soros controls the media.
This is an email that went out, I believe it
yesterday. This is from Trump asking for money,
and there's not even the pretense anymore that
they are doing anything short of just completely
adopting the standard hardcore right wing
conspiracy theories. Trump's fundraising email
rights, friend of all the vile witch hunts and
schemes the radical left Democrats have concocted
since I first came down the golden escalator.
This one may truly be the most despicable
because they're not just trying to silence me.
They're trying to cancel out your vote. Soros
and his globalist cabal remember that Globalist
is often used as a catch all for Jews when
you can't when you can't say Jews. Soros and
his globalist cabal are attempting to buy out
the media, control the airwaves and guarantee
Crooked Joe Biden whatever coverage he desires.
Then they source a headline from the Western
Journal. Not exactly The Associated Press, which
says Soros group are preparing to swoop in and
buy major media company out of bankruptcy report,
which is a completely different thing from we're
trying to control the media and give Joe Biden
the coverage he wants. This is your standard
generic anti-Semitic conspiracy theory. And what
you know, people who look at this stuff closely
and have been following it for a long time as
we have. You understand that this is all about.
Some people just work in media, but the Jews
conspire to control the media. And that's the kind
of kernel that's at the heart of many of these
anti-Semitic media control or control banking.
That's another one. Soros and whoever else,
they're controlling banking. It's not just, oh,
there are groups that are different, differently
represented in different industries. Okay. Well,
we could talk about historical reasons why that
is. No big deal. Great conversation. We've had
it many times. No, it's about the cabal, the
globalist cabal, Soros and other Jews. You
have to understand that that's what's under the
surface here. Working together. To their benefit
and to the detriment of everybody else. To control
the media, etc.. So we don't have to spend a lot
of time on this in the sense that I know many of
you already know and understand this conspiracy
theory. It doesn't need to be explained to you and
those of you who at this point insist on denying
that that's what this conspiracy theory is. I'm
certainly not going to be able to convince you,
but the news is, for lack of a better term, Trump
now overtly doing this in fundraising emails,